this is a real mystery right here show
someone the poster of this movie who
hasn't seen the trailer and be like who
do you think the star of this movie is
I'll give you a
[Music]
second so argy's the new Matthew Von
film stars Bryce Dallas Howard and Sam
Rockwell that's right kids in case you
didn't get it those two are the stars
anyhow Bryce Dallas Howard plays an
author she writes spy novels turns out
her novels are very close to reality so
she gets wrapped into the Spy World
spies organizations are trying to kill
her Sam Rockwell plays a spy who's
helping her out so it's the two of them
navigating that situation and yeah Henry
Cav's in it kind of as a character in
her fictional novel who is not the star
of this movie regardless of what the
poster looks like Henry Cav's in this
movie for about 5 minutes max don't go
into this all like hey loved Man from
Uncle let's do it it's just going to
piss you off there are other things in
this movie to be pissed about and as
I've said Matthew Von is hit or miss
with me funny enough Argy is hit and
Miss with me can't say it's the best and
worst of Matthew vau as there's nothing
in here that really does compare to
Matthew Von's best but it's undeniably
some Matthew Von fun and Lowe's wrapped
into one over paded over stuffed 2hour
20 minute package Sam Rockwell and Bryce
Dallas Howard I thought they were good
in the movie Sam Rockwell in particular
is a standout who once again showcases
his great comedic timing important for
this movie cuz I feel like when the
humor landed it was usually because of
him this movie plays up the camp in that
Matthew vaugh kind of way sometimes it's
fun sometimes you're like and that's the
movie having its head up its own ass
like that hallway action sequence with
all the smoke I know it's trying to be
this cool stylistic moment problem is I
couldn't see anything cuz everything was
in smoke so it felt like a waste of time
the very next action sequence is far
more ridiculous but I could actually see
what was happening so I actually had fun
with it it is no doubt the most
ridiculous action sequence in the entire
thing if you want reality this ain't it
what can I say it was ridiculous it was
also fun so so worked for me man I
usually like to have the positives in
one group and the negatives in another
group and that's how the structure of
the video goes not this one it's all
intermittently woven into itself which
is kind of how the movie feels so it's
on brand speaking of which this movie
doesn't really have structure this movie
is about three movies I can think of at
the top of my head two of which I can
actually tell you cuz the third one if I
tell you oh it reminds me of this movie
you're going to know reveal it's kind of
a spoiler to even compare it but they
feel like isolated incidents like the
movies that all right we're going with
this Vibe all right now we're on to
another vibe it's totally different
movie all right now we're on to another
vibe at first she's an author who's
working with a spy they're trying to
figure out what's going on with the big
bads she thinks like a spy so she's like
all right how would I write this oh hey
this is what I would do kind of like
Will Graham and Hannibal only you know
without the serial killings they're just
like all right no more of that we're not
doing that anymore in this movie now
we're Enemy of the State then from there
it's all right no more of that we're
doing something else feel like I need to
emphasize with those particular
comparisons it's always the uh comedic
versions of those it is always and
remains its comedic campy fun buddy Spy
Thriller this movie actually had some
fun twists turns and reveals I got to
give at that I was having fun with those
by about the end of this thing you're
like okay you're Jumping the Shark big
time here that didn't even need to be a
thing why is that a thing now so
preoccupied with whether or not they
could they didn't stop to think if they
should even when it would cut to Henry
caval imagery it started to annoy me at
first you notice this whole spy sequence
as shown in the trailer and then you
find out oh hey that's just a story and
she's reading it and that's who AR guy
is he's this fictional character in
these books that she's written but an
action sequence will be going down and
it will oddly and awkwardly cut to
instead of Sam Rockwell Sam Rockwell
will turn into Argy and then back to Sam
Rockwell while he's fighting could have
gone for one scene the first action
sequence in the train being that but the
movie kept doing it I was like okay I
think we're done with that now you oh
there it is again okay you're still
going to do it I'm I'm just say there it
is again all right all things in
moderation let's leave the audience
wanting more but therein lies the
problem the Big Wigs don't want to leave
the audience wanting more when they're
paying for that Henry caval mug why pay
for Henry caval to be a character in a
book that's read once in the movie when
you could shoehorn him into the movie
and put him front and center in the
poster worst of all that's just how it
came across it came across like they had
to keep putting Henry caval into the
movie because they paid for him waste
not and yeah movie's too long dude 2
hours 20 minutes no no more than two for
this this would have been a fine 2hour
package the cat was cute is funny I'm
like this is lazy key jangling for cat
ladies what Henry Cav wasn't enough to
get the ladies in the theater you had to
put the CGI cat in there Hollywood
pulling out all the stops to reel in
that female demographic using everything
except good writing and last but not
least as it feels like I've been
bitching about this movie far more than
I intended to the CGI yes the CGI the
green screen goes from noticeable to
downright bad it's an epidemic in movies
I see it more and more it's like that
phrase The New Normal well this is the
new normal feel like everyone just
accepts it like oh yeah Hollywood movie
with bad CGI I know it's how they do it
now it's a bummer it's sad once again
I'm an to advocate for the CGI artists
it's not their fault we've heard the
horror stories of the working conditions
it's kind of like all right 100 meter
dash with that Boulder tied around your
waist Ready set go oh you didn't make it
in a second guess you suck at your job
overworked underpaid ridiculous
deadlines whose art is going to thrive
in those conditions to be fair I don't
know how it went down with this movie
that's just what I've seen in Hollywood
generally speaking one more movie with
bad CGI makes me think oh well yep still
happening in the end Argyle it had its
moments also had some really ridiculous
some of which I had fun with some
of which I thought was just sloppy and
lazy whereas say the first Kingsman
movie felt like it was this revitalized
re-energized take on a spy Thriller
Argyle on the other hand feels like
style over substance it's not a total
watch but you might need the aid of your
own poison
yeah now it's a party funny enough
pretty sure at the end they cause
another Exxon Valdes type crisis but no
one ever mentions it it's like wait did
did they just oh I guess guess not all
right so Argy have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite spy movie that's a pretty big
one Why not pick your spy movie whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see
more
[Music]